Hello and welcome to fire of learning Rome and China,
two of the ancient world's greatest civilizations though contemporaries,
these two cultures existed isolated from each other on opposite sides of the
world in between them,
mountains,
deserts,
forests,
rivers,
and numerous other peoples and language barriers.
In a world where transportation was primitive and the hypothetical journey from
Rome to China or vice versa could have taken months or even longer.
Despite this distance,
it seems fascinating to ask,
did the Romans and Chinese know of each other?
If so,
what contact,
if any,
did they have with each other and if they were in contact,
what does this mean for their history and all of world history?
Well,
here today on fire,
I'm learning.
We will be answering these questions and more so let's get to it.
Before we begin,
I would like to thank sound wizard,
Pamela and Mork,
Jeff Smith,
Jonathan Yansen or Jensen and Michael would for being our most recent supporters
on patriotic.
They join these supporters listed here who helped make these videos possible now
than Rome and China.
A good place to start with.
This question is about the second century BC.
It is around this time that we see both Rome and China are large,
powerful,
influential empires,
not by coincidence.
It is in this time that we see the emergence of something called the Silk Road.
The Silk Road,
as you can probably guess,
it doesn't refer to an actual single road.
It's a name for a number of trade routes extending all the way from eastern Asia
where China ruled to the Mediterranean where Rome ruled.
The name comes from the most lucrative objects to travel along this route.
Silk.
Those silk would be found all across this route.
It was made solely in China.
It's production being a closely guarded secret because of how important it was
to Chinese wells along the Silk Road.
Many other objects moved back and forth as well.
Spices,
metals,
precious stones,
wine,
ivory,
cotton,
glassware and other things as well like knowledge,
ideas,
technology,
culture,
and unfortunately disease.
This was not the first time long distance trade had ever occurred.
There is some evidence that Chinese cell committed it's way west from centuries
prior even,
but the growth of these two empires made trade much more common and profitable.
Did Chinese silk end up in Rome?
Did Roman coins end up in China?
Absolutely.
Roman coins,
for example,
have even been found in places like Vietnam and Japan.
This tells us that yes,
the Chinese and Romans did have at least indirect contact and we're at least
superficially aware of each other.
China knew that there must have been a great power far to the West and Rome
likewise knew the same about the far east and that it was from these mysterious
places that goods went to and came from.
However,
this doesn't tell us everything we need to know.
The term is silk road is an invention by historians.
In recent centuries,
very few people would have actually gone the whole distance from western Europe
to China as there wouldn't have been much reason to at least economically
anyway.
Most traders moved goods from one city to another neighboring one and then
traders there would move the goods to another city and so on and so forth.
Basically with the civilizations of the Near East and South Asia functioning as
middlemen.
We have to wonder though if at some point a Roman looked at the,
made in China tag on his silk and asked,
what is China?
Did the two civilizations ever come to know more about each other?
You could safely guests that the common Roman or the common Chinese person could
have gotten their whole lives without knowing about the other or wondering much
about it.
But the leaders,
scholars,
and merchants of these nations absolutely did know about each other and there is
evidence of direct contact on multiple occasions.
The Romans called China,
either steady [inaudible],
the land of silk or Sienna,
a word,
basically with the same root as the word China.
A number of Roman historians such as virtual and Ptolemy wrote about China,
although many Romans seemed to be less certain about where exactly it was and
some even confused it with other nations and this reconstruction of a Roman map,
we can see that they weren't always far off though likewise,
the Chinese referred to Rome as dot chain,
meaning the other China for the Chinese to equate Rome to themselves as a clear
sign that they were respected by them.
And Rome seems to fit into the ancient Chinese conception of the world as being
the other great empire on the other side of the world.
The Chinese were also aware of the ancient Greeks,
especially as Alexander's Empire stretched even further east than Rome ever did
hear.
Even is a Chinese depiction of a blue wide Greek soldier and above him a center
of figure of Greek mythology from around the time of Alexander the Chinese
correctly believe that Rome was the successor to the Greek states of the east.
Historians have found a number of records clearly describing events of direct
contact.
That is to say Romans visiting China and the Chinese visiting Rome.
These accounts range from explorer is venturing into the unknown to intentional
voyages by merchants and ambassadors and insights are even given into the trade
and resources of the other nation that governments,
ways of life,
physical descriptions of the terrain,
physical descriptions of the people,
descriptions of the cities,
and much more,
not always accurate.
Some accounts included fantastical legends,
but important all the same.
The first recorded incident of the Chinese visiting Rome took place during the
reign of the emperor Augustus when the Roman empire was becoming a true empire.
Though this incident may have been more mercantile in nature then diplomatic.
The first clear example of Rome reaching China seems to be later on and he
[inaudible] the Chinese recorded people from the West arriving to their country
and claiming to serve a rule there named Andre.
Andre won most likely refers to Marcus or alias Antoninus.
This incident occurred around the time that trade between Roman China began to
pick up and historians consider the second century Aidy as the beginning of
clear established Roman Chinese relations.
So yes,
Roman China not only knew of each other's existence and bits and pieces about
each other,
but in the second century,
a d pad established relations and from time to time visited each other.
Trade was the driving force behind these two nations,
meaning each other.
People were simply following the goods and wanted to know more about where they
went to and came from.
And contact and knowledge only became more and more common.
As the centuries progressed.
However,
the Persians,
the powerful middleman between Roman China,
we're uncomfortable with the two powers interacting directly and discouraged it
on multiple occasions.
Even going so far as to block trade routes to prevent interaction.
The simple reason was how much money they were making simply by being in the
middle of the Silk Road.
It would have been difficult to actually bypass Persia,
but if Roman China were to work something out excluding,
it would have been bad news for them.
Persia and the states which would arise in the region we now call Iran would act
as the main middleman between Roman China right up until the fall of the eastern
Roman empire in 1453 while interest in trade would have accounted for the vast
majority of reasons to interact was that all that came down to,
I mean certainly much more was going on and if we could hear the stories of
these explorers and merchants,
they would undoubtedly be fascinating,
but some story seem to believe there were even more complex interactions,
possibly even intermarriage and warfare regarding warfare.
While there was certainly never a war between Rome and China,
some historians have speculated that Roman soldier is captured in the battle of
car high.
Around 53 BC made their way eastward as Persian slaves where they later were put
into the service of the Xiong.
New Armies fighting against the Chinese.
Chinese sources indicate that some foreign soldiers fighting in the battle of
Gog formed a strange fish scale formation,
possibly the infamous Roman testudo formation historian,
homer h dubs even went on to suggest that these soldiers later settled in
eastern Asia.
Though historical and genetic evidence is less supportive of this having
occurred and the foreign soldiers at Gigi,
we're uncertain to have been Romans some suggests that they were Greek
descendants of Alexander's empire,
but they may not have been Europeans or in near easterners at all.
We of course have to mention as well both the huns who moved into Europe around
the fourth century,
a d and the Mongols who moved into eastern Europe and the Near East and the
Middle Ages.
Neither of these groups were Chinese historians aren't 100% sure where the huns
came from,
likely Central Asia,
but possibly farther east.
And the mangoes of course came from the north of China and Modern Day Mongolia.
However,
focusing on the larger picture of Western and eastern contact,
both groups were affected by an effected to the larger politics of the day in
both empires,
especially the Mongols,
the Hanuk invasions of Europe,
who were possibly influenced by migrations that began by being pushed west by
China and likely heavily influenced the future dramatic barbarian migrations
that led to the fall of the western Roman Empire.
But ironically,
the Mongols who conquered China likely played a role in prolonging the life of
the Roman Empire at the time known to Westerners as the Byzantine Empire by
invading their rivals.
Exploring the relations between these ancient civilizations gives us a very
important insight into what the perspectives and lives of past people's were
like an important insight into how human civilization as a whole developed.
It was a time when the world was nowhere near as connected as it is today,
but not as far apart as we might've assumed.
As I said,
however,
it is a great shame that perhaps the greatest stories of Romans in China or
Chinese and Rome maybe lost forever.
Some of you may remember the media talking about the Chinese skeletons having
been discovered in Britain dating back to Roman Times while the claim that these
skeletons are Chinese was based on very bad evidence,
such things were not impossible and it's interesting to consider how these
things may have played out.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
If you did,
I'd invite you to come check out some other cool content we have here on fire
learning like the history of Rome documentary.
I invite you to subscribe to not miss out on future videos as well to help with
the cost of production.
Fire of learning does take donations on Patrion,
the link to which you can find in the description.
You can support the channel with as little as a $1 contribution.
However,
simply subscribing to our youtube channel for free is also a large health
special.
Thanks again to our patrion supporters listed here.
We're also on Instagram and Facebook,
so come check us out there to thank you for watching.